[Aplausos]
[Música]
esta charla se titula el cirujano trans
humanista en cierta forma es una
redundancia porque los cirujanos el
primero que existió siempre nos hemos
salido de la tecnología para nuestras
intervenciones
porque la definición del transhumanismo
en su forma más pura y sencilla
la mejora del ser humano mediante la
tecnología
se imaginan ustedes un hospital en el
que las cosas siempre se hagan del mismo
modo he tenido que escuchar tantas y
tantas veces esta lapidante frase de
gonzalo pitcher aquí las cosas siempre
se han hecho así no inventes a mí
personalmente me aterroriza la idea y
creo que los grandes avances de la
medicina y más concretamente de la
cirugía precisamente han venido de esos
cirujanos inquietos y curiosos que han
cambiado a lo largo de los siglos las
reglas del juego gracias a su tenacidad
hace casi 5 años yo trabajaba como
cirujano y unión en el departamento de
cirugía colorrectal de un hospital en
mallorca mi vida era bastante
confortable en aquel momento vivía en
una isla paradisíaca con muchas
comodidades y en el trabajo había
alcanzado objetivos que de algún modo me
habían otorgado o al menos eso yo creía
cierto estatus en el mundo de la cirugía
de un modo inusualmente precoz y gracias
al desarrollo pionero de tecnologías
como la cirugía guiada por fluorescencia
que hoy día son una realidad
increíble pero de algún modo mi vida
personal y mi proyecto de evolución
profesional se habían estancado o
simplemente acomodado hacía tiempo que
vivía en una felicidad no de todo plena
y eso consiguió algo peligroso me hizo
perder la ilusión
pero aquel año algo sucedió que volvió a
revolucionarlo todo sufrió una crisis
personal que me hizo tocar fondo pero al
mismo modo pisarlo para impulso y
saltar con más ganas que nunca me apoye
en la gente que quiero me ayudaron a
reponerme y a superarme decidí
enfrentarme a nuevos retos no sólo en el
plano profesional sino también en el
personal en octubre de 2017 agarré de
nuevo mi mochila y me fui a corea del
sur a conocer al profesor en cirugía
robótica sean hankin
me fui con el objetivo de seguir
avanzando a nivel de tecnología
quirúrgica ya según porque a pesar de
ser como marte para un gaditano como yo
es el lugar más increíble del planeta en
lo que concierne a la simbiosis de la
civilización humana con las máquinas
fue una experiencia alucinante en la que
me sentí en varias ocasiones como en una
película del futuro la robótica permite
mediante el filtro de una máquina
superar las limitaciones inherentes a
las vulnerabilidades del cirujano y
desarrollar procedimientos min invasivos
muy precisos hasta hace años impensables
y lo más importante al servicio de la
humanidad
o sea transhumanismo en estado puro
desgraciadamente influenciada por la
ciencia ficción la visión trans
humanista de una futura humanidad
diferente ha generado mucha confusión y
control agresividad
en la cirugía ocurre del mismo modo
continuamente
el cáncer de recto al cual he dedicado
mucho trabajo durante los últimos años
ha experimentado un cambio radical en
esta década se trata de una enfermedad
en la que hasta hace muy poco la única
opción curativa era la cirugía una
cirugía agresiva y de algún modo con
muchas consecuencias colaterales pero
esto está cambiando el pensamiento
científico innovador de diferentes
expertos a los cuales he tenido la
suerte de conocer por el mundo han dicho
que este concepto esté cambiando
también somos capaces de ofrecer a
determinados pacientes opciones de
curación no quirúrgicas que pasan por el
desarrollo de moléculas específicas para
atacar la biología propia de cada tumor
de recto llegará pronto el día en el que
como los cánceres de recto en muchos
otros y gracias a la innovación podamos
curar tan sólo con pastillas o vacunas
dolencias que todavía hoy necesitamos
una cirugía invasiva lo cual me dejará
sin curro sí pues soy cirujano pero será
por una buena causa
creen que el camino de estos cirujanos
innovadores fue fácil
yo tengo claro que no
del mismo modo que el desarrollo de la
genética nos ha permitido encontrar el
mecanismo para vencer el coronavirus a
través de la manipulación de la rn viral
llegará el día en el que ya no
necesitaremos la cirugía pero tampoco
las pastillas para combatir las
enfermedades pues seremos capaces de
anticiparnos a ellas
mi pasión aquella que me da el
equilibrio en los desafíos profesionales
es el surfing
el ser humano tiene la capacidad de
poder cuando de verdad quieren las cosas
a través de su poderosa mente y el apoyo
de los demás
antes dice
tecnología poco a poco iría tomando el
relevo de mis tareas y que quizás algún
día me enviara al paro pero yo no estoy
aquí para ser solamente cirujano
estoy para hacer gonzalo martín martín y
he aprendido a que puedo reciclarme en
cosas que me apasionan o que pueden
llegar a apasionarme incluso tanto como
la cirugía
puedo poner un chiringuito en mi querido
calle para enseñar por ejemplo a los
chavales de surfear o dedicarme a la
cocina sería de viajes
y compartir experiencias con quien
quiera escucharme a través de charlas
ted como estamos haciendo hoy y si me da
por imaginar pues probablemente muchas
cosas más
yo quiero tener capacidad adaptativa
para enfrentarme a la incertidumbre
creciente del futuro que se aproxima una
velocidad exponencial porque las cosas
no son como son sino como las percibimos
las personas positivas atraen a la gente
ya los sucesos positivos seamos
positivos confiemos y apoyemos en la
tecnología como un gran aliado
y para terminar me gustaría que todos
ustedes me acompañaran a mi teatro de
los sueños vamos a entrar en el
quirófano
hemos llegado ahí está todo el equipo
vamos a darle un aplauso a todo lo que
cada día llega en los quirófanos del
mundo innovando para dar esperanza y
saludo a otros seres humanos son
enfermeras auxiliares celadores
cirujanos la necesitan ingenieros
gracias gracias a todos